it's friday and that means it's time for
friday follies and for that we turn to
fox news contributor raymond arroyo all
right ray joe biden
had a he had a bit of a topsy-turvy week
of public events and
he seems to my eye he seems to be
kind of reverting back to his old
routines
laura i think your eye does not deceive
you
on monday the president repeated a line
that has gotten him in trouble in the
past
this is tonight's marquee malarkey bunch
of milwaukee
i swear to god when he left scranton
when cole died my dad was not a
was he was a salesperson he wasn't a
coal miner my
great-grandpa was only his
great-grandpop
was not a coal miner either laura he was
an engineer
who did not extract coal from anything
now
this is an old lie that biden fessed up
to
back in 2004. hell i might be president
now if it weren't for the fact that i
said my
i had an uncle who was a coal miner
turned out into anybody in the coal
mines you know i mean really i tried
that crap you
you know it didn't work you know i'm
from scranton pennsylvania i figured
there had to be a coal miner somewhere
in the family
nothing huh nothing nicole it was an
engineer i mean
laura how do you like that admission i
tried that
crap before it seems he keeps
trying it and it's not working out very
well remember this is what killed and he
referenced it there
the 1988 presidential campaign he stole
that
speech from neil kinnick the labor
secretary in the uk
referencing relatives who worked in the
coal mines turned out
never happened and the washington post
this week they said well
biden went too far but we're not giving
him pinocchio oh my god
unbelievable no wait first of all i i
keep seeing him and now that was
17 years ago okay well
he wasn't a spring chicken back then but
doesn't it seem like
number one aging is a is tough right
that's for all of us aging stuff
but my goodness he's like a different
person doesn't look
the same person laura whether it's due
to his age or his mental state we are
reaching a place with president biden
where
to him the plagiarized personal
narratives are fusing with reality
but it doesn't make them true these days
facts and names
they're all elusive to them this is the
president from wednesday listen
and mayor remember mayor pisarro
i want to thank you for being here and i
know it probably embarrasses me to point
you out and say that but
you predicted and practiced
your disciplines on land and sea
you've shown that you are salty we have
to make sure that women
have the chance to succeed and throw
thrive throughout their careers some
chinese saying it says
women hold up half the world
it's an absolute stupid position
not to make sure they represent at least
half of what we do
there's a lot of absolute stupidity
there laura firstly
he is quoting mao the chinese dictator
and that line is women hold up half the
sky
not the world by the way that bit of
chinese propaganda was intended to push
women
into the factories he loves borrowing
lines from foreign politicians
doesn't matter who they are just take
the line and make it your own yeah
raymond you're speaking to the u.s coast
guard
and you're quoting the notorious
dictator
in a positive way of your chief military
adversary does anyone else find this to
be
i mean you could open up like the
quotable quotes
and any day of the week and just like
why not go with irma bombeck or
something right why go
why it would be an improvement over a
guy who wiped out 80 million people yeah
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else